riots have swept through eastern
Indonesia with protesters burning
buildings clashing with police and
blocking roads West Papua Legislative
Building and a prison were also torched
now West Papua and Papua provinces are
in Indonesia's East Far East so to speak
they've been home to a long-running
separatist movement against the
Indonesian government now pop wants a
Indonesia illegally annexed the
territory in the 1960s those tensions
were evident last week nearly 3,000
kilometers away in Surabaya in central
Indonesia here are more than 40 pop when
students were allegedly racially abused
as police detained them during Indonesia
as Independence Day celebrations this
set the stage for the latest protests
[Applause]
Indonesian police and protesters clash
near sarong prison and west papua
officials say over two hundred and fifty
prisoners escaped on monday when the
jail was set ablaze protestors also
damaged parts of the airport and set
regional government officers on fire as
they went on the rampage in the city
violence - in the provincial capital
manokwari as rage spilled out onto the
streets videos like this circulated
widely on the internet have whipped up
the protesters anger activists say it
shows poopoo and students being called
monkeys during an operation by security
forces in East Java the students were
accused of damaging the Indonesian flag
and taken into custody
police later said no evidence was found
against them Indonesia's Minister for
political legal and security affairs has
promised an investigation the government
regrets the incident involving the
Indonesian flag in East Java province
which is now under investigation the
incident was followed by negative
statements and has triggered unrest in
several parts of Papua and West Papua
provinces are also responding to the
allegations of racist abuse on social
media sharing images and hashtags with
the slogan we are not monkeys
Indonesia's president has urged an end
to the rioting telling the protesters
it's okay to be emotional but it's
better to be forgiving and someone who's
been following these protesters human
rights lawyer Veronica c'mon we can't
say where she's joining us from for
security reasons Veronica good to have
you on the program with us we just
played a report and on the basis of that
I need to ask you is there some sense of
discrimination that you think people in
Papua and West Papua are responding to
yes it's totally the the original sin of
Indonesia towards West Papuan people
it's racism all along and finally the
rich tipping point this past two days so
when the people say that oh it's due to
the incident in Surabaya where the West
Papua students dorm were attacked and
raises lots of monkeys it's just it's
just bigger this they finally have
fridge tipping point how would you
describe so father
the Indonesian state's response to the
protests and also overall the West Papua
and Papua have been witnessing a
separatist movement for many decades now
how would you rate the response of the
Indonesian state the response of you
nation government has been finally they
are not using security approach since
the since the beginning in the 1960s
until now Indonesia being using security
approach that been failing and that's
why that are these past few days
mutually under Indonesian law if you
want to protest you have to submit a
letter of notification three days prior
to the protest but this protests this
large-scale protest there are no
notification letter submitted to the
police and but yet they can take the
streets are you saying that the
Indonesian government does not know how
to deal with the protests and the
popular feelings in Papua and West Papua
I don't think so because the yesterday
the Indonesian president and chief
security minister already responded to
this large-scale protest but the the
president didn't apologize but instead
the president said that don't you may be
emotional but let's forgive each other
of course today the West Papua took the
stress again the National Police as well
say that they are going after social
media accounts which distribute
provocative news about West Papua
instead of going after the real
perpetrators of racist attack attackers
so it's been really disappointing so far
right we'll have to leave it there for
the time being Veronica oh man thank you
very much for joining us